well first episode of my podcast
we're gonna call it the wonder dome for
now but i have my
very special guest today for the first
episode i had to have the real rejects
greg
alba and john humphrey what's up guys
what's up
warren how's it going cosmic wonder oh
my god
oh wow oh my god it's a wonder to be
here why don't you put your face on
camera oh
my god that's such a winning smile
because i'm nothing compared to you two
beautiful gentlemen
hey i could yes and that everyone's just
gonna compare me to the real rejects and
be like just stop the real rejects
already got you just leave it
no man you're you're waiting yourself
short buddy i love looking at you warren
thanks for having us for your first
guest on
on this particular segment on my podcast
that i'm starting right now that i hope
to have for a
long time you were the first ones i
thought of you guys for this reason
right here they're hilarious and they
have great insight on
really all movies out there so if you
guys don't know who the real rejects are
uh you need to and you need to go
subscribe to them right now
i think that you brought us on here
because they're like it's the first one
so i can mess this one up
yeah you're using us as scratch paper
not at all no we had to start with the
best but speaking of congrats to greg
recently got engaged
yes i did hey yes big week for you too
because you're also writing a movie that
you announced
yeah yeah i mean i i got i have a couple
of big announcements this week
and they're both gonna probably be able
to deliver around the same time
engagements that take a long time and
then we're only in pre-production on the
movie right now so
haven't even started like the official
filming of it it's all going to take a
long time so
immediately i'm blown up with questions
of when's this coming out when's this
coming out i'm like
we don't know yet but the premiere and
your wedding gonna be the same event
that's happening
all right you just gotta we really want
to take our time to make sure this is
good
all right that's a good way to go about
it but thank you i really appreciate
that
yeah absolutely absolutely so today
we're going to be talking about
spider-man 3
black panther 2 and the mandalorian but
we're going to start with spider-man 3
huge multiverse movie right so it's
supposedly
supposed to be that's a redundant
statement but
multiverse some people are upset that
it's
not just you know tom holland spider-man
some want
toby mcguire somewhat andrew garfield
miles morales spider-gwen everybody
what do you guys think do you think it
should be all about tom holland or you
think it should be this big multiverse
spider-verse movie
all right look i'm gonna let john go
first because
since we're the first guests here i'm
gonna do whatever i can to give the
controversial opinions
i know what you probably want warren is
sincerity and honesty today
well i say let's have some fun and get
both
opinions in here so john and i agree on
way too many things so i'm going to
start you out with the milk toast
publicly agreeable opinion getting the
opinion out there john
guys personally spider-man 3
i think we should not lose ourselves in
the weeds of multiverse
fun it should certainly be nucleus
focused on tom holland however i think
it's a tremendous
idea with full potential for magnificent
anticipation going forward if they
introduce
the multiverse some of these crazy
things they've been talking about
use them sparingly and then go back to
them for future installments and expand
from there
i would love to see toby maguire and
andrew garfield and all these people
show up i just don't want them to hijack
the film so what is what's your exact
question here warren
that they shouldn't be in spite like
they shouldn't do all these other
additional characters in here or should
just
be tom holland focus should it not be a
spider-verse movie is what you're saying
i think right because oops sorry no
please warren your show
um because so we went from
so let's go let's go to spider-man far
from home ending oh spider-man
everybody knows he's peter parker now
right everybody knows peter parker
spider-man
you didn't see spoilers i've been lying
about a lot of these comic books
anyway well just so you know um
everybody at the end of spiderman far
from home
finds out that peter parker is
spider-man so now you know
sorry so quite a twist wow
why we walk out halfway through yeah why
didn't we give up on that movie
it was so bad he just walked up to make
him a hero
come on i came for evil i came for bad
guy mysterio what's happening
well okay look as much as people are
probably like
it's gonna distract it's gonna distract
you know
people thought that about iron man in
spider-man homecoming and you know what
what's up
i just said they did yep sorry oh no
that's good i like when people agree
with me when you disagree
oh this venom comes out of me
[Laughter]
are we sure we're the best first guest
to read at
i think people thought he would distract
from there and uh he didn't
and you know as fun as tom holland is
we've had
what is this like the 25th spider-man
movie for crying out loud
where it's mainly focused on peter
parker and you know what a lot of people
think is the best spider-man movie
i think real spider-man fans look at me
i have a beanie and a spider-man shirt
that must mean i am the representation
of real spider-man fans
a lot of people think that spider-man
movie is
spider-man into the spider-verse even
though it was an into the spider-verse
film
i thought that it still made it a miles
morales movie at the end of the day
so what's to stop them from pulling off
something similar here just in a live
action format
you have tom holland as the main
character you have his peter parker but
you throwing a whole bunch of other
people in there this phase of marvel is
where we're getting wacky and
crazy wanda vision multiverse of madness
now let's explore that with spider-man a
big part of what makes the mcu so cool
is that they've slowly been bringing the
essence and the heart and the soul
of the comic books this animated format
into live action
now that we have the spider-verse
animated movie
i say we can pull it off
throw more people in there i heard
there's doctor octopus is going to be in
there
how he's alive no idea
[Laughter]
i'm satisfied with that easter egg
warren
you're a cosmic wonder your video's
hidden so much off of awesome easter
eggs
you're gonna want you you're gonna want
i want everything you're gonna
i want it all right then you're gonna
get everything on breaking that crap the
most
comprehensive spider you're gonna want
to be on my
side of this so this is now turned into
i guess competition between movies
like i've got the wrong energy i'm not
saying
why everyone's going to have similar
let's just
let's have some fun and mix this up all
right all right
well i'm okay where are you i agree with
both of you i'm in the middle right so i
agree with both of you halfway and
disagree with both of you halfway
excellent so i think this neutral piece
of crap yes
i hate to be that guy don't be
wishy-washy warren
you gotta appeal to the masses right
give the
well well andrew andrew garfield didn't
get three movies but i was gonna say
uh you know toby mcguire got three
movies andrew got two they were all
focused on them
but at the same time you're right greg
it's been done before
right so you kind of gotta add new
things and especially in this
new mcu i'll call it when everything's
about to just get blown
up it would be cool for this to kind of
blow up as well right
and it's going to sync with it because
it's part of the mcu right so i've
specifically been told
that there's a very specific order one
division doctor strange spider-man 3
for a reason one division is going to
kind of like
break those realms and kind of create
the multiverse doctor strange is going
to really really explore it
and then a lot of that multiverse is
going to collide into ours
in spider-man 3. so i agree that they
can bring all these other different
spider-man in
and all these other different characters
but they should still have that focus
on tom holland's peter parker like they
did on miles so i still think it should
be his movie
because i mean it's his movie right i
mean
so and it's not like
i actually like toby maguire spiderman
the best i like tom holland spider-man
but i like tobey maguire's the best but
it's not like
it's the right choice tom holland fan
there you go
it's not like i'm like oh tom holland is
the best ever i love the guy
but uh i'm not like fan crazy over him
as spider-man
but i do think he should get that
kind of you know focus maybe it doesn't
have to be the absolute center of
attention but
because i do i really want to see toby
and andrew in there
i would love to see some magical way
emma stone in there is gwen stacy that's
another one of those like
doc up thing he's dead i don't care just
throw him in he's in other movies right
but he's dead
multiverse well that doesn't explain
time travel multiverse throw him in
there like
i'm fine with that throw gwen in there
for some reason
as long as they bring an italian
spider-man i think that's all
well i think too that you can use this
as an opportunity
you know how x-men days of future past
properly
gave a good wraparound especially after
the crap that x-men the last stand was
how they kind of fixed that
up spider-man threes uh toby maguire's
did not have a solid ending
and to do they're supposed to be a part
four as well they're supposed to be four
right yeah
yeah and then andrew garfield obviously
that didn't finish
so i think you can wrap those up in some
way whether it's just like a real
it's all about the writing and the
execution so you just have at least
a scene or two that's really good that
gives you uh
closure on those like
leave them behind you know and then yeah
yeah but i think
for the most part even though i tried
playing devil's advocate
i feel like we all landed so great right
right too lost in the weeds but we've
seen this a million times let's have
some fun
people right to your point he's gonna be
fine
he's tom holland he's got christmas
stuff he's in so
many movies right now like they just
keep coming out yeah
too many movies oh i well like you know
they're in the new russo brothers movie
i'm like is there anything this guy's
not in right now
it's like the new nicholas cage or
something the guy's in like a billion
videos
tom holland is in bad debt i hope
someone says that into an interview
with with tom holland you're like the
new nicholas james
nick nick cage aren't you yeah yeah hey
you played ghost rider he was with
marvel
there you go i think as long as this
spider-verse movie
or this spider-man movie only keeps
keeps it with
in spider-man world like when okay
if i'm hearing that they're they're
throwing in characters that are obvious
like if you threw the mandarin in there
who's obviously more
associated with that or iron man then
it'd be like
too much dial it back but if you're if
it's a spider-man related
mainly spider-man related characters
then all right
i'm a-okay i think we're gonna be fine
no one needs to get their panties in a
bunch
well because it's still a spider-man
movie at that point right because
they're spider-man characters
but if you start throwing the mandarin
then it's it's not it's just like
avengers end game right it's just
everything
yeah i mean doctor strange i think is
just going to be a cameo i think he's in
a hat
like in in thor ragnarok
dr strange had an important scene uh it
was a short scene but it was an
important
one to move the plot along to help
explain some stuff
and i think that's exactly what we're
going to get with doctor strange in
spider-man 3.
i'm hearing mentor so maybe he will be
what
iron man was in that but i don't think
it's going to be as
big of a role as everyone has made it
out to be like
he is the main supporting character i
don't think right right that big
well and like you said in the beginning
iron man didn't steal the show away
in homecoming right yeah um you know
happy or anybody else didn't really
steal it and far from home
so it's okay to have a mentor right and
that's fine but
but something going back on something
you said
like the closure to the original
spider-man 3 with toby enclosure for
andrew
you know multiverse of madness is
directed by sam raimi
so this is all lined up in a very
specific way and right in the middle is
sam raimi to kind of
get that opportunity to wrap it up so
you're saying it's like linked to oz the
great and the powerful
i totally see it there's magic in that
world they're bringing magic
into the embassy james franco is coming
out she's playing both characters he's
worked with james franco before
happy to be in one of those spider-man
movies i forget who is that who that's
directed by
but he happened to be in one of those
well yeah because after the the tobey
maguire timeline like there's a huge
accident and then the world devolves
into like different pockets of wasteland
and that's where oz rises up you know
and harry osborne becomes the wizard
exactly that's exactly how it works is
this bitcoin we figured it out sorry
marvel but we
we got yeah it's done if you do read
something else cause we got you
i'm gonna be so pissed off this bit
better stay in the video
uh whatever point you were making uh yes
and uh 100 percent warned
i totally agree with you
tell me how to think warren tell me what
to think
um you should just devote all your
videos to telling people to subscribe to
my channel
you know that sounds like a great idea i
think you'd get a lot of subscribers
at the end so if you guys like this
video watch the subscribe button
thanks for watching the real rejects
don't forget to we're gonna subscribe
tell them to subscribe we should just do
that one month anyways just like
take like a week where at the end of our
videos we just say subscribe to the real
reject subscribe because
just throw people off that could be a
great experience
this is the content not words then you
hand it off to the editor to decide what
people would actually want to listen to
right yeah right ooh chris
but um you know i'm excited for it
because i think
the possibilities are endless right i
mean of course
literally like you said greg as long as
they stick within the spider-man
universe
right just put spider-man characters in
there you could do whatever you want
and i'm pretty sure everybody's going to
eat it up
yeah no matter what complaints we have
that are preconceived notions
we're all still showing up oh yeah and
oh kids are paying 100
and i and that be honest to be serious
for a second
because this is the most serious thing
i've had to discuss all year undoubtedly
to be serious i think that
um you're doing great what was my point
damn it all right i got so caught up in
my little sarcastic remark i'm so sorry
um
damn what was my point the everyone's
gonna go see them oh yeah
i do think we gotta get to a point
though when when tom holland spiderman
uh peter parker is officially a freaking
adult
yeah yeah we can't have like mentor this
and mentor that and
and and he has to be able to stand on
his own a man of a million mentors like
he doesn't
he has to get to that point
but you know i think that it's having me
think of
like how in civil war the comics
spider-man unveiled his identity and
then it's funny how
spider-man debuted in the mcu in civil
war
in civil war right and so i feel like
they're kind of doing this hodgepodge
of borrowing different like like how
they've always done
but especially now that the world knows
peter parker's identity
uh spider-man's identity is peter parker
yeah i think they're kind of borrowing
some angles from there as well
you know so i think you do have to get
to a point though eventually
where he can stand on his own two feet
and it doesn't require
this mcu character that mcu character
and i
especially feel like in the part threes
of these movies
is when they start to go a little bit
banana sandwich when it comes to
when it comes to their like thor
ragnarok had hulk in there
uh and then true um what was the other
one captain america civil war
war is literally just an avengers movie
i mean avengers was already like a
crossover of sorts with an infinity war
the part three of the avengers movies is
when he got
right whoa we're going all the way you
know so i think this is when they
they usually go all out uh is when the
part three is to really
do it yep maybe they'll be the first big
hollywood spider-man franchise to nail
that part three yeah
all right it would be nice yeah they
have a really good opportunity to do it
here
but you know i i've seen a lot of people
i've seen a lot of memes actually where
it's like oh spider-man like you know
tony stark's gone he finally can make it
on his own
doctor strange confirmed to be a mentor
and says spider-man at spider-man 3.
i was like what it's like this was it
this is the opportunity
for him to like be an adult i don't
think there's ever been a more
justifiable reason for him to have some
help
yeah that's true exactly right
i would love i would love it if they
make the choice that peter doesn't want
the mentor and and dr strange is kind of
forcing it on
yeah just have it be the rebellious punk
peter installment
right i'm just pushing
[Laughter]
so my theory is that and i don't think i
i don't think it's gonna happen this way
because i think peter park or
sorry i think toby mcguire and andrew
garfield are going to have at least
somewhat
of a prominent role um more than like a
quick flash right but
i had a theory that doctor strange is
going to like mentor him he's going to
counsel him
and peter's gonna be like it's too hard
i have all this stuff going on and then
doctor strange is like
you're not the only spider-man to deal
with this and then he shows them these
other universes where
toby mcguire is fighting these people
right and then he shows
andrew garfield like fighting these
people and he's just like see all these
other spider-man have to deal with it
too
i thought that would be a cool way to do
it but i think they need to involve them
a little bit more than go hey look
here's another universe look what they
did there right because then at that
point it's almost like a flashback to
the other movies so
well then you've got him being more of a
chaperone on like an interdimensional
field trip than being a full-on mentor
that's my question though is what is
this whole thing about him being a
mentor
what is he mentoring him to do
you know be more super than before
right yeah i guess iron man is mentor
and you see that he's guiding him
on the principles of being a hero and
how to go about like you're
if you're nothing without the suit then
you don't deserve the suit or whatever
the hell that quote is right
but that was like such an important
moment for that character
to find himself that he doesn't need to
rely on the suit
and so i think that like what what is
when they say mentoring
is it just a guide on how to handle
universe jumping like that's what i
think so it sounds like to me is
it's not a mentor it's just a dude who's
gonna help out with this maybe he will
train peter in the art of really tapping
into his
aura and using his you know spiritual
realm yeah with the mystical art he's
gonna he's gonna
surgeon yes
he won't have the suit he'll start off
fighting as peter and then he'll go off
into the astral plane to to finally come
out victorious yeah
exactly there it is i think john nailed
it on the head we just figured out
spider-man 3
we figured out doctor strange multiverse
of madness marvel should hire us
spoiler alert for this podcast spoilers
they can all agree that it's almost like
star wars fans like
you can complain about the movies and
you can complain about whatever you want
but they're in the theaters watching the
next movie no matter what it is i think
we can agree that we're all going to be
there watching the next spider-man
no matter what it is it's just going to
be exciting
about it than most star wars fans would
be a new star wars movie
problem i mean i think that as long as
it doesn't get to the point where we
have to course correct we're a-okay
we didn't even correspond with or the
dark world other than change up the tone
yeah that's true you know but they kept
that canon
they didn't go we didn't do this no they
right yeah
as long as you don't get to that point
where we're a-okay
yeah i agree i agree so okay black
panther
black panther two unfortunately chadwick
boseman is gone
there's a lot of talks right now about
replacing him some people want him
recast they don't want t'challa gone
they just want a different actor to play
it some people are not okay with that
some people are there's also a rumor
there's going to be two black panthers
shuri and then another one oh
shit's coming off what do we got
oh don't get distracted all right this
is just
i'm totally distracted
please you're looking at your new black
panther right here this is a true
professional right here i just changed
this is a lot smoother nope you gotta
keep the realism
it's very very it's raw oh still
okay still spider-man crossover
spider-panther is this
pandering did you say no to whom you say
pandering so who could possibly be
pandering to
i'm sorry what were we talking about i
just really felt the need to change my
shirt for no
we were talking about shang chi and the
legend of the ten rings
yes chiang chi of course we're talking
about shang chi in the legend of the ten
rings which uh you know you would have
known had you not been
fully nude moments ago do you ever do
you have another does you have another
shirt
uh yeah for the third time sure by any
chance
yeah then there's a there's a matching
underwear set too that's gonna play in
later
ah okay yeah we'll save that for the
final
the final you know the peak of the of
this episode
so okay you got the black panther shirt
on
john greg thoughts should they recast
t'challa or have him disappear from the
movie whether it's a death
or they just say he's on a mission or
something and bringing a new black
panther
thoughts john why don't you go first
all right well i i came up with a
reference based joke that i'm not going
to use
oh because here in this moment i was
like that's a bad one person movie to
reference
all right i think they should make a one
person movie
all about t'challa cast a body double
d age the face stick it on him and just
completely ignore
reality and just make a full-on
franchise from here with uh you know a
cgi chadwick boseman i feel like people
will not miss a beat they'll love it
that's my honest take wow you
and you okay interesting you ruined the
bit
oh no was i supposed to be sincere
sincerely i
established this i am the scientist
you're the one that i would
talk the hot takes and then you just
there are more hot ticks there are more
hot takes all right i take it
i'll give the real answer
that's got to be what it is
i think they should be respectful to
chadwick
no no honest opinions honest um
i think that i don't think you need a
body double i don't think you need a cgi
i feel like his death like the the cries
were heard around the world when it came
to the passing of chadwick bozeman
his name is so associated with blackness
panther already
we all know he's he's gone we all know
he's passed on
and i think you can just start it off
where
you don't he he's already been he's
already passed
it's like the there's such a
relationship with the audience
already i feel like audiences
would be understanding i just think the
movie needs to deal
with the grieving of him i don't think
you just need a
you know like he's gone have five
minutes and then
neymar's in town oh crap we got bigger
fish to fry we get more
that's like an underlying theme of grief
throughout which is why i'm kind of
surprised to hear that they're gonna
start
shooting by july um because i thought
you need a brand new screenplay yeah
yeah
yeah yeah so i think
uh i think i would have thought so too
uh the current underneath it
feels like they are honoring when i say
honor i don't just mean like
rest in peace chadwick bozeman at the
end or you do your marvel logo and it's
all chadwick bosun which i think they
should do
you want him to still feel like a
presence right throughout the movie
that is just as impactful in his absence
as it was in his presence the first time
yeah i'm not sure
i know there's movies that have done
that i'm just trying to
think trying to think of an example
that's not fast seven well the first
time's just the ending
i mean even in like rocky that's not
even a strong example but like rocky
balboa
adrian's dead when the movie starts and
her
dealing with the loss of her is kind of
something that looms throughout the
movie
and and i think that's like that's
that's a weak it's still not the
strength yeah something out there that
is like
right there that's like that's the
perfect example yeah but i think
what is it that needs to i think that's
the most
integral part because it's hard for me
to get like all fixated and focused uh i
mean it's great for your channel
but for me personally i get like a
really like hard time going
i don't know i'm not really pumped
thinking about namor or
shuri or two black panthers i'm like how
are they gonna handle the storytelling
sure in honor of this man's legacy and
the only way he can do that is by honors
by dealing with the loss of t'challa so
i think he has to be
i think you just start off where he's
gone or maybe he that's or kind of yeah
like his funeral yeah you could do that
you could start off with his funeral
right yeah that's kind of what i had in
mind too like maybe just start with his
funeral
right and then sure he's talking to his
her mom and they're just like
you know i can't believe he's gone and
then maybe you know umbaku is like
i'm gonna go kill that man maybe it was
an atlantean that did it right and it's
like
i don't know what the stories like let's
like you said i thought they would for
sure
push it back and they're filming already
it's
it's really crazy because again i
thought they would do a completely
different story but it seems like they
might be
kind of sticking to the same story now
there's been rumors
for a while that namor was supposed to
show up right and he's going to be the
villain
and there's that long feud between
atlantis and wakanda so maybe they just
say an atlantean
killed him right and it starts off with
a funeral or something like that and
they mourn for him
and the whole movie may be about i don't
want to say like you should do a revenge
movie
because i don't know if you don't want
that like bad
take up some kind of mantle of like a
vengeance like if you're
using these real circumstances as
you know a spiritual aspect of the movie
i feel like a revenge mission might
actually kind of
cheapen some of that
yeah have you seen right that's what i'm
saying right
morales video game yet
no you're not a spider-man fan what are
you doing what did you ask me about what
are you doing warren okay there's
there's this big part of miles morales
in that game where
peter's not dead but the big part of
that game is him having to find his own
um
like embrace his own identity and he
keeps having to
like keep comparing himself to others
primarily
um you know peter parker spider-man he's
not just embracing his own identity and
he has this internal struggle and i
think if you did something like that
if let's say shuri is the new black
panther and having to deal with how
t'challa would have done this or
she needs t'challa's guidance like
really feeling like she needs t'challa
i think that would be like the ultimate
way to
still honor him is that why you it
causes for a good reflection like you
don't need
the death to be a villain killed them we
need revenge i think you can have
something though where he is dead in the
beginning and she
she has to deal with this really big
thing now and all she could think of is
how t'challa would have done this or
what t'challa would have done
differently
yeah how she would have been guided and
how would my brother do it
the only way i can see uh working in
that regard well and that can be a
really rich emotional arc
too i think as well and i i think it
just you know
spitballing i would almost if it was me
i might even make some of the
circumstances not you know
directly real life but yeah maybe
t'challa had some sort of
inter like a condition or something that
you know it's not a villain it's not an
outside force it's just a fact of life
and then yeah having
shuri or whoever have to take up the
mantle right they're not ready for that
they're grieving for their own family
member and they have to
you know get the job done so to speak
and ascend
you know reach within and find a level
of power and perseverance
you know taking that inspiration from
you know the presence of t'challa and
what he stood for but then also learning
to transcend the shadow of
you know i feel like that could actually
in a weird again like the circumstances
are horrible but in reacting to them i
feel like the movie actually has
a potential moment to make it or like a
really richly
impactful movie you know and to
again yeah i think whatever they do they
should absolutely
embrace the circumstances because i
think you're absolutely right about that
is
everybody in the world who cares about
this stuff at all knows what happened
and you know
had something to say about it and had a
feeling about it and so yeah you can't
uh yeah it would be very foolish i think
and outside of
what i understand now to be the marvel
sensibility like it just doesn't seem
like something kevin feige would do
to not you know be pragmatic and meet
reality and use that as sort of a a big
part of how to move forward and also i
think black panther ii
not only should they do it because of
the passing of chadwick boseman have a
more serious tone
the black panther one is a pretty
serious movie like there's
there's humor in there yeah it is
it is interactions but there's not the
quote-unquote marvel humor there's none
of
there's not that stuff you know there's
no joss whedon sure dialogue or tycho
right there's no hulk or banner jumping
out of the you know playing and there's
no comedy
then the whole comes out right yeah and
the characters like shuri
sailing right what are you wearing what
are what are you like when he's talking
about the sandals or something the shoes
um
yeah like like those kind of lines are
are in there but it's yeah
it's it's not it doesn't have the marvel
humor so i think
that this is one where i'm like well
it's already kind of a serious movie
might as well just embrace that and
and roll with that and and i think it is
i feel like ryan coogler would be great
at dealing with
judging yeah i mean judging by his
previous films
yeah i think i think so too
yeah i think you both hit it on the head
like really hit the nail on the head
there
i think you you definitely have to
address it right
and you show no you don't shed the death
um i heard a report that they're gonna
show him die in battle and i'm just like
no don't do that don't cji his body with
the body that you can't do that he died
in real life you can't like
relive it but i i agree i think it needs
to start off with
like a funeral in like the morning and
then it's like you said john
you know something happens and she's
grieving and all of a sudden she has to
deal with
that and then she thinks what would my
brother do
right if it is shuri now here's a
question i do have though
so it's been confirmed in the mcu tie-in
book
the wakanda files that shuri's basically
created a new heart-shaped derb
right which is what gives the black
panther his powers or her powers
so let's say shuri becomes new black
panther she partakes of the heart-shaped
herb she goes to the astral plane do
they
do a cgi chadwick at that time when
she sees her ancestors and stuff like
that or do you just kind of
avoid that or do you maybe make it a
panther or something you know what do
you
what do you think if you do like a cgi
version of him
i don't think he i don't think he should
talk like
yeah you know i don't know what the what
the moment would be
necessarily um but i think
it's got to be something that feels a
little bit heavenly and
it's because you know when there there's
like some pretty heavy scenes
in the first black panther when he when
he goes to the astral plane but they're
like really emotionally learning
like heavy information and has some
serious conflict i don't think it should
be
that i i think it should be something
that feels like
um like a longing or missing and it
shouldn't be
a uh something that's it is like
reassuring if his presence is there but
also heartbreaking because it's
it's significant confirming that yeah
he's he's moved on
to the next realm and i will be leaving
here too to go back to reality soon you
know
it's a temporary plane and it you know
it hurts when you have something like
that even if it is you know a benevolent
moment or a moment of you know
influx of emotion because you do have
that presence briefly you know it's
yeah as long as he doesn't talk i think
you as it could just be
a good visual scene no dialogue
an exchange between them coming to peace
with something like towards the end of
the movie if they do it
i feel like they probably have enough
footage left over too that they could
what if it's well that's what i was
gonna say so what if it's like maybe old
footage or something right
or like his old record old record of his
voice just saying something reassuring
to her
digital any audio yeah yeah don't get a
voice
don't make don't make new ones don't
don't princess
and you're fine
of throwing him in there like
like actually fast seven is
uh furious for yourself seven yeah
furious seven
is a great example of that you know like
even though
now i can look at it and go oh wait
that's clearly a cgi
face they put like they clearly altered
him at the same time though
it doesn't emotionally lose its effect
and they don't have
that paul walker speak it's all visual
yeah
and i think something more along those
lines and less rogue one
and we're okay something that again yeah
just
has their presence in their aura but
doesn't mean like oh they're
they're full once you make him start
talking i feel like it it takes you to
that realm of like okay now i know
exactly he wasn't here this isn't real
footage this is you know movie magic
yeah and so yeah if you have something
tangible right
okay yep that makes sense don't yeah
make it as aura
and ethereal oriented as possible
yeah i'd agree with that because and and
i thought i almost had what and i don't
i don't i don't really know how it would
be perceived but almost make it like an
you know they had some black panthers in
one of those times like actually you
know
well they weren't real but you know cgi
panther maybe it's just like a panther
and it comes up and it kind of nuzzles
up next to her like rubs are in the
light like a cat would you know and
she's kind of like hi brother or
something like that you know what i mean
it's just like comforting or something
like that
i don't know how that would do but that
was kind of like a thought that i had
because i'm the same way i'm like you
shouldn't make him talk
probably shouldn't cjm and if you do
just have him there and smile or
something like that
um so but it's a you know it's it's a
hard situation nobody knew he was
sick nobody knew he had cancer nobody
knew he was gonna die he actually
thought he was gonna make it so
it's just a really sad situation and i i
hope they
hope they do what we're talking about i
hope they have
it be that presence in the movie like
you were saying but have it almost be
uplifting
what would my brother do what would the
last black panther do he was a great man
i want to be like him exactly
how can i be like him use my idea
yeah so okay last year but not least
what
um okay so the mandalorian it's been
awesome super exciting now okay ahsoka's
coming
i haven't seen her yet but since
ahsoka's coming
the big question lately has been are we
going to see
luke skywalker obi-wan kenobi
did you just change your shirt yes i did
warren
yes i did i believe that the shirt you
wear
has people think you must be the biggest
fan in the world
and you must know what you're talking
about so i changed
manipulation that's right you know this
is like
it's covered judge it by its t-shirt
[Music]
why is quotes from john
well greg since you magically have an
epic shirt on would
you like to take this away do you think
we're gonna see
luke skywalker obi-wan kenobi someone
in a future episode of the mandalorian
since we're getting ahsoka
specifically those two no anybody
we'll probably see someone we'll see
some new characters i think i think
they'll add some new characters
okay let me rephrase it i guess do you
think we'll see one of those two
both of those two neither what do you
think i think that
luke is going to enter the show and then
take over
it's going to become the luke and ben
comedy hour i don't think we'll see obi
wan
um because he's not dead i don't think
we'll see obi wan
um he's oh he's dead now yeah yes yeah
he's uh
he's he'll be a force at this point yeah
i don't think we're gonna see him
um luke skywalker i
don't think we'll see luke skywalker
either
i i don't although i would venture to
say that if we do see luke skywalker it
wouldn't be this season
i think it would be next season if we
were to see luke
because right now they've been doing a
lot of their tie-ins with clone wars and
rebels you know
right right right feel like people
excited enough as it is for that
and i think you know getting them in
there is is just joyous
and if you got luke in there already i
feel like it kind of
takes away some of the spotlight i i
still doubt we'd see
see him there i feel like we're more
likely to get
a little bit more of like a random like
one of the
like a droid like r2d2 or
someone connected you know like if
you've got to
i wouldn't mind seeing threepio in there
just because he's the
and like they do go to tatooine a few
times
right right in this series as it is so i
think if anyone were more likely to see
is that's the only reason why i'd say if
there's anyone we're likely to see it
might be luke skywalker considering
that's where his home is
and um yeah or maybe we'll see baby kylo
ren the way how we saw
young right and that was my yeah yeah
they'll have no awards they'll drop the
child off with you know the the jedi
and whoever did to train him and then
it'll turn out that he was just across
the tent from
little ben before uh there you go
baby yoda was in the room for the
sequels i think
i think that my my most like
the the guest that i would most venture
to believe is possible
i think we'll actually see yoda um yes
he's dead he's forced
at this time but um
i think it's called the veil of the
force um that it's established
near the end of rebels where wherever
ezra bridger pulled the socaton out to
save her from the darth vader fight
uh yeah i think it's called the veil of
the force you're wearing the shirt come
on greg
i know the shirt's supposed to give me
powers we discussed
this when talking about the skywalk no i
don't know
no i just watched that recently yeah i
just wanna make sure i got it right okay
anyway so um yeah and i think that's
just with the socatano she because she's
not
socatano's not technically a jedi
anymore she left the jedi order but i
think she has ways of
she's but she's still she's still
essentially a jedi
she's like it's one of those things more
more than
jango fett essentially being amanda like
he's not a mandalorian
is essentially a jedi and and
and she would have the ability to
communicate through the force
of communicating with yoda in some way
and i think just with
the idea of the presence of the child
ahsoka tano
knows who yoda is she's had a direct
interaction with yoda many times
yeah so odds are she's gonna see that
baby
and be like that little mother effort
looks like soda
so i need to get in with yoda yeah
yeah and and so i feel like if anyone's
likely to
show up out of the star wars movies i
think it's going to be yoda
i mean the only reason i could really
think for bringing in a
obi-wan i mean because you said that
then i'm like well you know
then you could i guess have him conjure
up obi-wan force ghost or something like
that but i i i
need there's no really need to do that
other than perhaps
just reminding people about the obi-wan
show and to tune into that
it's coming it's tied well i don't put
it past them different eras but whatever
you know right yeah i would have put it
past them but
i think i would have to agree i think
the necessity of it
probably isn't there yeah i think i
don't think you need to
but you're 100 right because i've had
the same thought ahsoka
knows who yoda is right so she's
automatically going to be like
this freaking dude in the jedi council
who preaches the order
had a kid with somebody right she's
gonna think it's his kid or something
like that right yeah
so you know and there and there was
yaddle i don't know if they're gonna
like make that
cannon into everything that's going on
but
you know she was there too she was one
of their kind species we don't know what
it is yet
but she's gonna she's automatically
gonna be like well we gotta go find yoda
it's clearly the same species right
yeah so that would make sense i don't
know if she knows if yoda's dead yet
though because
we're returning i think she knows if
yoda's dead
when did rebels i don't know i don't
know what they're gonna
do i wonder if they're gonna change
anything
i'm trying to remember my timelines here
because i know rebels uh the battle of
endor does happen
like in the finale of you're not there
but i know it takes place off-screen
so but i don't know if she knows if
yoda's actually dead yet
because he dies in return of the jedi
but this is where mandalorian's like
five years after return of the jedi
so if that's the case she might have
heard
word about him being dead
well worth assuming i mean like but yoda
was in isolation for a very long time
and difficult to get a hold of
but he does show up in rebels when like
ezra bridger will talk with him through
the force so
maybe yeah i i think that's what's i
heard
i heard one from star wars the channel
star wars theory actually
is uh about like we watched a video that
was
talking about the possibility and it
sounded cool and
and plausible of mace windu showing up
in the mandalorian and why
and i actually really like it and i
think it'd be really cool
however if we're talking about one that
i think we'll actually see sooner than
later i i
it's ahsoka tano trying to get in touch
with yoda i think that's the
most likely one to happen weirdly enough
of all the classic star wars characters
that we
could be pulling into the world of the
mandalorian this is just a stray thought
but
the one that makes the most sense to me
is is han and chewie
because like you know when we come back
in the sequels they're still tooling
around the galaxy doing scavenger stuff
and they make a lot of sense just in the
world that the mandalorian occupies and
the kinds of things
that's true yeah they end up doing there
and you know
they could easily run into him somewhere
so like that
seems like one that it probably is
impossible because i doubt harrison ford
would want to do that and i don't know
if anybody would be like
yeah salt and aaron right come on back
but
i could fathom like a natural way for
that to happen perhaps more so
yeah see i think with what you're saying
is you're 100 right because
it makes the most sense it does for them
but then again at that time though
because because in force awakens is when
han
got back into you know like things were
the whole kylo ren situation or or ben
situation
and then he got back into his old ways
but at the end of return of the jedi
he's not he's not continuing to do that
you know he's he's a part of the
republic
and yeah and so he's you know he's like
settling down with leia he's probably
like giving him
yeah keeping track of star wars
timelines it makes the biggest
difference
yeah smuggler does make the most sense
to show up but in terms of where han is
by the end of return of the jedi
in five years yeah
still a good dad still send that all
right well to
end it i'll change the question is there
anyone you would like to see show up in
the mandalorian despite
whatever andrew garfield
jonah jameson it's everybody
bring them all i want everybody i like
it
that's a good call back thanks man that
was a good one that's good
that's all i'm impressed i'm
i think we just ended it there if it's
the best joker right there
yeah now i got to top it i mean the ones
i
i named are are the ones i would like to
see
um you know undoubtedly uh but i think
i i would like to see mace windu's show
like star wars theory
that when they put that pretty cool when
he put that one out there i was like
you know what that would be cool because
of the fact that boba fett's back now
and mace windu and boba fett was
hell-bent on killing him
in the clone wars like getting revenge
for that that's true
yeah and you could bring that kind of
full circle like like how in rebels when
obi-wan and darth maul have a show
a showdown you kind of have a similar
thing here
where mace windu actually did survive in
revenge of the sith and went into hiding
the similar yoda went into hiding they
were both
they had a chris tucker jackie chan
moment you go this way i go that way
yeah i don't i don't i i feel like he
could he could have survived that
super strong jedi one of the most
powerful jedi i mean
he had his own lightsaber granted that's
the sam jackson thing but yeah
we didn't see the light leave his eyes
and sam jackson will never
die so i yeah no like i know he doesn't
i would love that theory i would like to
see that too
yeah well there's a lot of exciting
things kind of in my world in your world
and
just kind of the world that we live in
right now um so
we're going to be talking about a lot
more to come in future episodes and i
hope you guys will join me
in future episodes as well everybody the
real rejects if you are not subscribed
to their channel you definitely should
be
two awesome guys greg and john again
greg congratulations on your engagement
thanks but a good week for you it's been
a good week but then we had a couple of
low-performing videos
and it just it's a terrible week oh no
my mood i am a very circumstantial kind
of individual
so if something goes wrong in this light
it's like oh it's going going great
suddenly boom low performing video those
youtube analytics show up
i take it out on everyone especially
oh no everyone to save john
go over to the real rejects
please help john out come on guys
sometimes i can blink for help
the signals are there no one's picking
up on it come on someone will one day
you'll catch my dirty well guys thank
you so much again for being on the very
first episode of my podcast
i hope everyone enjoyed having the real
rejects on here hope everyone enjoyed
the first episode of the podcast more to
come i'm going to try to get them out
every thursday one big last thank you to
the real rejects for being on
here and you know what guys if you want
to give them a woof woof i'll let you
lead it out
thanks so much for watching woof